call of duty world war ii beta came out
a little early
and we thought we'd show off the intro
cinematic as well as the intros to the
five divisions you can play as
we'll have tons of more cod content
coming up so if there's anything you'd
like to see
add them to the conversation below and
consider hitting that sub button to stay
up to date with all of our coverage
thanks for watching
this is headquarters your home away from
home and the center of your time here
off the front line
if you're not out there in the field
this is your place to advance your
career
so gear up train hard get to know your
fellow soldiers
we're well supplied but you've got a lot
to learn
every man and woman on this beach knows
this was just the first step
in pushing back the germans we're
counting on you to help us
push through to the rhine
i'm captain john p andrews and i'm here
to recruit you
to the us army infantry as infantrymen
you will experience more combat than any
other branch in our multinational force
you will be the tip of the spear for
that reason
you'll receive individual skills
training and be made fit to fight
the instruction you'll receive
emphasizes individual rifle marksmanship
and hand-to-hand combat so you will be
able to engage the enemy at any range
at longer engagement distances you'll
rely on your skills as infantry riflemen
to destroy the enemy
up close you will receive instructions
on how to fight with the bayonet
sweat and training saves blood in battle
as long as you have your brothers in
arms and your rifle
you are unstoppable and if something
tries to stop you
show them what a bayonet can do to
anything in the way
let's get to work
welcome to the airborne we are the most
well-trained physically fit and
battle-ready unit in the us army
being a sky soldier requires peak
physical fitness mental and emotional
toughness and unhesitating courage
it doesn't get any more dangerous than
this we're the first in the fight and
we're the last thing opposition wants to
see
we are hunters from the sky if you think
you've got the guts then gear up
get on board and let's go kick some axis
ass
i'm captain john p pay close attention
the sooner we get the introductions out
of the way the sooner we can get to
blowing things up
my name is major james parks of the
royal british armoured division
our armored forces have one mission and
one mission only
engage and destroy the enemy we
specialize in direct combat with
opposing armored forces
strong points and fighting positions
we're also frequently called upon to
provide for direct fire support for our
comrades in the infantry
a weapon that is issued in our branch
down to the squad level is the light
machine gun
as a member of the armored division it
will be your duty to clear the way for
our brothers in arms
if we don't do our job then they can't
do theirs
we fight for king and country but most
of all
we fight for each other it is an honor
to be armored never forget that
now let's get started shall we
welcome soldiers to the canadian
mountain division
the most elite unit in the entire allied
armed forces
if you want to run headlong and to
access strongholds try the infantry
but if you want to make your shot count
then we have a place for you you are the
eyes of the unit
you take in everything the whole world
lives between your
crosshairs find your vantage point
and execute the mission they can't hear
us they can't see us
by the time they detect us it's too late
if you have a keen eye and a steady hand
if you have the patience to wait for the
perfect shot
if you can quiet the world around you
and do what needs to be done
then look nowhere else but the mountain
division
attention welcome to the resistance
we do not have the luxury of time as our
enemies are closing in
so i will be brief we are the pioneers
of a new expeditionary force
specializing in sabotage
and covert operations we operate by
night
raiding supply points for weapons and
explosives
including the incendiary shotgun shells
that spark flames
creating a hailstorm of fire that
consume our enemies
if you want to join us you must be
willing to sacrifice everything
for the good of your countrymen we
are the french expeditionary force we
are the fire that will burn down the
axis empire to the ground
viv la resistance
you